Olá vocês sabiam que apenas uma colher
de sopa de vinagre de maçã antes de uma
refeição pode reduzir os níveis de
glicose ou melhor dizendo o pico de
glicose no sangue em até
30% na prática significa que o vinagre
de maçã pode ajudar a prevenir e a
controlar o Diabetes melhorando
problemas como Resistência à insulina
inflamação crônica o que ajuda
infinitamente a proteger o coração e os
vasos sanguíneos
contribuindo para uma vida mais longa ao
controlar esses níveis de açúcar no
sangue você também consegue controlar
melhor a fome evitar os ataques de
compulsão alimentar ajudando no processo
de emagrecimento e manutenção de um peso
saudável com a Glicemia controlada você
evita também aquelas oscilações bruscas
de energia que muitas vezes resultam em
cansaço dificuldade de concentração
durante durante o dia mas infelizmente
muitas pessoas estão usando o vinagre de
maçã de forma errada Há muitos vídeos e
informações por aí às vezes as pessoas
acabam se confundindo então eu vou
explicar da forma mais simples possível
para que vocês entendam Quais são esses
erros Ok o primeiro erro que muitas
pessoas cometem ao usar o vinagre de
maçã é não optar por um produto de boa
qualidade Claro qualquer vinagre de maçã
pode oferecer alguns benefícios e
especialmente devido ao ácido acético
que é o responsável pela redução da
glicemia no entanto um vinagre de maçã
de alta qualidade como é o caso de um
orgânico não pauster e não filtrado
oferece muito mais vantagens esse tipo
de vinagre mantém uma fina teia de
resíduos flutuantes conhecida como mãe
que indica a presença de propriedades
naturais intactas essas partículas não
filtradas das maçãs incluem bactérias
benéficas conhecidas como pós bióticos
que são excelentes para a manutenção da
saúde intestinal melhorando a
biodiversidade do nosso microbioma
intestinal também contém enzimas e
fibras essenciais que são fundamentais
pra saúde gastrointestinal e com esses
benefícios extras você vai promover uma
digestão melhor uma absorção mais
eficiente de nutrientes por outro lado o
vinagre de maçã comum que é pauster
isado e filtrado geralmente não possui
essas características esse tipo de
vinagre é encontrado em embalagens de
plástico e ao manipulá-lo você percebe
que ele é totalmente sem resíduos a
paera e a filtragem remove muitas das
características das propriedades
benéficas reduzindo a quantidade de
enzimas e bactérias benéficas para
garantir todos esses benefícios é ideal
escolher um vinagre de maçã orgânico não
pauster e não filtrado algumas marcas
que eu recomendo são senhor vicino São
Francisco Fazenda São Roque brag e o
Italiano
lapastina sempre procure a versão
orgânica desses vinagres pois eles
oferecem muito mais vantagens pra saúde
o segundo erro comum ao consumir vinagre
de maçã é que eu já ouvir bastante no
consultório é o consumo excessivo muitas
vezes as pessoas começam a tomar uma
colher de sopa por dia sentem-se bem e
depois pensam bom eu vou incluir mais
vezes ao longo do dia apesar do vinagre
de maçã conter potássio naturalmente se
você consumir vinagre em excesso pode
causar sintomas adversos como diminuição
dos níveis de potássio no sangue por
isso você não pode exagerar no consumo
de vinagre de maçã a quantidade ideal é
de uma a duas colheres de sopa por dia
pra maioria das pessoas e no máximo
quatro colheres de sopa por dia é
importante começar devagar com uma
colher de chá diluía em um copo de água
e aumentar gradativamente até atingir a
quantidade recomendada Além disso o
consumo excessivo de vinagre de maçã
Pode sim interagir negativamente com
certos medicamentos por por exemplo se
você toma diuréticos que podem causar
perda de potássio a combinação com
vinagre de maçã em excesso pode
potencializar essa perda de mineral
potássio levando a problemas sérios
portanto é bem importante conversar com
o seu médico antes de adicionar vinagre
de maçã à sua rotina diária
especialmente se você tiver tomando
qualquer medicamento que afete os níveis
de potássio no sangue outro problema do
consumo excessivo de vinagre de maçã é
irritação gástrica que pode causar dor
de estômago e azia existe ainda um
problema mais raro mas grave que é a
acidose metabólica causado pela acidez
do vinagre de maçã isso ocorre quando o
pH do sangue muda devido ao consumo
excessivo de vinagre em um curto período
de tempo isso pode ser Fatal por exemplo
consumir meia garrafa de vinagre de maçã
de uma vez pode colocar você em risco
o terceiro erro a consumir vinagre de
maçã é tomá-lo no horário errado e
consequentemente não obter o benefício
desejado por exemplo se você consumir
vinagre de maçã em jejum pela manhã logo
ao acordar após um jejum de por exemplo
16 horas isso pode auxiliar na queima de
gordura no emagrecimento não estou
dizendo que ele fará milagre sozinho mas
quando combinado com o jejum o efeito
pode ser potencializado consumir vinagre
de maçã em jejum engana o corpo fazendo
pensar que está em um déficit calórico
mais profundo do que realmente está
aumentando assim a lipólise e a queima
de gordura isso provoca mudanças na
forma como as mitocôndrias
funcionam encorajando o corpo a usar
mais gordura como fonte de energia esse
processo pode ajudar na queima de
gordura visceral aquela gordura osa
dentro no abdômen que está associado a
doenças graves como a síndrome
metabólica e doenças cardíacas Além
disso tomar vinagre de maçã eem jejum
pode ajudar a evitar quedas de energia
durante o dia e aumentar a sensação de
saciedade na primeira
refeição outro benefício de consumir
vinagre de maçã pela manhã é o impulso
que ele dá ao sistema digestório
funcionando como uma espécie de detox a
maçã matéria prima do Vinagre é rico em
pectina uma fibra solúvel especial que
atua como suave laxante natural ajudando
na saúde intestinal e combatendo
problemas como intestino preso já
consumir vinagre de maçã nas refeições
logo quando você se senta para comer
pode ter um impacto muito positivo no
controle da glicemia o ácido acético do
vinagre afeta as enzimas que decompõe os
carboidratos e o açúcar resultando em
uma liberação mais enta de glicose no
sangue o que é extremamente benéfico
para quem tem diabetes resistência à
insulina ou está tentando evitar picos
de açúcar no sangue sabemos que esses
Picos são perigosos levando a condições
como pré-diabetes e resistência insulina
que podem resultar em doenças graves
como doenças
cardiovasculares metabólicas e até
câncer portanto controlar esses Picos
usando fgag de maçã pode ser uma
excelente estratégia Além disso muitos
que sofrem de doenças como refluxo ácido
que trazem desconforto devido ao ácido
do estômago voltando levando a tosse a z
queimação podem também se beneficiar ao
contrário do que muitos pensa o refluxo
ácido muitas vezes é causado pela falta
de acidez no estômago e não pelo excesso
Se esse for o seu caso tomar vinagre de
maçã junto às refeições pode equilibrar
a acidez evitar os sintomas de refluxo o
vinagre de maçã sendo um ácido ajuda na
digestão de proteínas e outros alimentos
melhorando a digestão como um todo agora
pessoal tomar vinagre de maçã antes de
dormir tem benefícios que se assemelham
aos já mencionados mas também oferece um
benefício específico um benefício para
quem acorda no meio da noite sem motivo
aparente se você acorda entre 2as e 6 da
manhã e depois não consegue voltar a
dormir isso pode estar relacionado aos
níveis de açúcar no sangue idealmente
todos nós deveríamos acordar pela manhã
com a glicemia em níveis saudáveis mas
para algumas pessoas isso não é a
realidade quando há resistência à
insulina ou uma tendência ao diabetes o
fígado pode produzir glicose Extra
durante à noite é aqui onde entra o
vinagre de maçã ajudando a evitar essa
produção excessiva de GC pelo fígado
durante a noite Além disso o vinagre de
maçã também contribui pra regulação da
secreção de insulina portanto para quem
tem flutuações nos níveis de glicose
seja Alta ou baixa o consumo regular de
vinagre de maçã pode ser muito benéfico
nesse caso a minha sugestão é misturar
uma colher de sopa de vinagre de maçã em
um copo cheio de água e tomar essa
mistura à noite um pouco antes de dormir
lembre-se também de que o vinagre de
maçã não substitui qualquer medicação
que você esteja tomando fica ligado
outras dicas importantes que também
podem ser erros comuns algumas pessoas
podem não tolerar o vinagre por conta de
algumas substâncias presentes nele que
causam sensibilidade como é o caso do
salicilato que também está presente na
aspirina e pode causar reações
respiratórias e na pele outra substância
é estamina já que o vinag é um produto
fermentado ele pode ter grandes
quantidades de histamina e pessoas
sensíveis a Amina podem ter sintomas de
alterações intestinais coceira na pele
espirros e obstrução nasal após consumir
vinagre pessoas com doença renal crônica
devem ter cautela se você tem problemas
como úlcera estomacal ou gastrite
erosiva não use vinagre de maçã a menos
que seu médico tenha avaliado e liberado
aprovado uso é sempre importante
conversar com o seu médico antes de
introduzir o vinagre de maçã na sua
rotina especialmente se você estiver
tomando medicamentos para diabetes ou
qualquer outra condição de saúde compar
os vídeos bem a vida de alguém pode
mudar também no canal
[Música]
dovv Muito obrigado pela sua atenção um
grande abraço um beijo no seu coração
você é feira